I actually don't but when I do it's
usually road range stuff where people
are driving stupid or whatever like the
typical stuff that you get mad at can't
even imagine well his mad is probably
like it's
[Music]
not welcome back to careful boys um what
is the most trivial thing about which
you have a very strong opinion oh dude
all my Tak Petty things that you're just
like strongly passionate
about everything that's this guy's life
yeah that's his whole existence yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think I think Nick
hates everything you know I think I
cooled off I I stopped doing that [__]
what happened what happened I like I
just started realizing that I'm wasting
my energy thinking about like sometimes
it is kind of be like to be funny cuz it
is funny to me to be have such a strong
opinion on something that's so small and
so menial wait so that means that was
real well kind of I think it's real a
little bit sometimes it is what's the
most recent thing that you got pissed
off at that was like it's not even a big
deal man let me tell you like it's not
real highand chicken oh you get pissed
that no not that kind of someone someone
didn't signal and they turned into your
lane oh recently it's been people riding
their bikes on um the sidewalk while I'm
walking my
dog oh that's hard if you have a dog
yeah that's some Nick done [__] though
yeah yeah yeah but cuz it's like dude
you're blazing down the street I'm
walking my dog and I'm walking and these
guys are just [__] they're they're
going down they're they're going pretty
fast like the tights type of cyclists or
like like [__] pun people trying to
get to work people trying to get to work
and I'm like it's 1100 a.m. I'm trying
to walk my [__] dog you you have any
sense at all you know by way you're
probably late to work it's 11:00 a.m. I
like you're never going to make it
you'll be nothing in this world that's
how I am you know no but I know it's
[__] so stupid but part of me just
like gets a little annoyed and I go it
doesn't matter and I just move on but it
is funnier to like really feel mad about
that and like say it to you guys would
you say you're not as angry as you
appear on the show oh yeah for sure I
think so I think you're angry or no you
think I'm angry at the little things nah
nah nah I think that you just juice it
here in a humorous way but like when
you're it's just you I think you're
raging that's what I think but it's like
an inner ra it's an inner rage that you
don't show on the outside though is that
true I think I I could picture Nick at
like ack McDonald's or whatever and then
a little bit of ketchup squirts on his
you know shirt and he goes to the
napkins thing and it's empty he's like
mother I like to blame people for is you
know and then and then he reaches over
the counter grabs the guy by the collar
and [__] pulls them pulls I throw a
burrito at the [__] lady dude and
like how'd you get a burrito it's
McDonald's I get mad at like
bureaucratic [__] you know what I mean
like like where I have to go to the DMV
I'm like dude this is [__] this is
stupid this is is dumb well dude the
Vegas DMV you don't even have that tell
them about it y this is no joke I was
dude dealing with the Vegas government
it's a different [__] feeling than
you want to know what's [__] crazy
you can get a corn dog at the DMV I
swear to [__] God say that did you
say you have popcorn there's concession
stands you get a Slurpee you get a
[__] Pizza Vegas calendar crazy dude
play Slots was your last I good shot no
but there's [__] Pizza you could get
Milk Duds buy [__] snacks and [__]
it's crazy and they're nice dude if you
forget something they don't tell you to
[__] off go no they don't throw your
paperwork back at your face yeah like I
had to have Nikki like like take a
picture of a document that I didn't have
with me and like send it to me and like
this lady was like don't worry I'll wait
for you it's all good I was like are you
kidding me in California she'd be
throwing me out of here she had security
taking
me and and she be rubbing her [__]
[__] while she trying to
come
like they love that [__] so mean dude
that place sucks she's like I'm [__]
squir it sounds like most of your
problems come from living in la oh yeah
kind of the traffic the bicycle is look
anytime you guys bring up [__] about how
like cool Vegas is I can't argue with it
that's why I'm upset is that's why I sit
in silence cuz I'm like yeah you're
probably [__] right and I have no
rebuttal pry chill it's one of those
things where you're like man this
[__] Desert Oasis [__] town and
then you start doing things differently
like wait the DMV here actually is nice
and they actually help me fill up the
paperwork if I don't understand it what
the [__] what's your guys' pothole
situation what is that what what's yeah
I don't pot what is that oh is that like
marijuana we have marijuana over there
pot holes in California is is what
trivial thing that I get upset about
that's not trivial dude that's your
everyday freaking see that's what I'm
talk about thank you for supporting me
dog these [__] you know these guys
wouldn't even know is it trivial to get
upset if there's a log line at the post
office like if you're trying to like
mail something yeah I think lines in
general make me mad you're supposed to
get in line right but dude one time I
was just I just needed to like mail one
thing and I know you could just drop it
off in the box but like isn't it better
to like get it certified or whatever and
so I went to the post office and I was
like Yo dude this Line's too long dude
so you know what I did I went to UPS and
I know like their [__] is kind of shitty
too cuz I actually got a package that
was lost from UPS I was like [__] but
there's no line so I just went so you'd
rather have no line have your [__] get
lost yeah yeah yeah I don't blame you
because I was like dude I do not want to
wait here just for this one thing you
know so that those are like the little
things that I get upset at my trivial
thing that I really rage about and this
is so dumb but I really do get mad about
it whenever I see like if you go on
Reddit gaming or whatever and you see
people like they got a picture of their
kid playing like regular Nintendo and it
say raising them right or whatever and
I'm like I'm like let me just tell you
something right now dude you are
excluding your kid from like what's
happening right now in gaming when they
go to school they don't relate to like
what their friends are talking about
gaming cuz you got them playing [__]
Pac-Man likeu Mega Man one yeah and so
like they're like wait what's all this
new [__] and stuff like that and then
they just grw up to hate you yep because
that you need to know that your kid
played Mario 1 or whatever they like the
Vintage stuff yeah compared to now it's
like cool yeah Mario 1 and everyone's
like yeah that's the best one I'm like
yeah no it's not the best one that's
true it's like everyone has Sega and
Super Nintendo and then you have Atari
at home exactly plus there's a fallacy
that because those games are harder that
they get better at games and that's not
true you get B quicker cuz then they'll
play a today game and go what the [__]
is all these features and menus and [__]
why is it in
3D 3D yeah you just get better at old
old games it's like that's it oh you
know what pisses me off [__] uh cops
that are just in the corner oh yeah the
radar gun that's the most [__] [__]
just trying to catch [__] you
ever catch them before they're like when
they're about to set up that's the most
[__] you'll see them like go on the
freeway they look like they look sneaky
yeah they back into the shadow of the
[__] tree and [__] I'm like dude you
went through all this training to
[__] just cash put a branch
over a branch to cover it go do some
real cop [__] whoop a criminal's ass or
something I whoop a criminal's ass I'll
tell you I'll tell you an irrational
thing that pisses me off and it's super
not it's not fair at all I get mad when
I see girls out walking with the [__]
boot like they twisted their ankle and
they have to wear that
boot I hate that I hate that wait what
boot when one of the boot is you know
when they have to wear that foot brace
they they put it on they put on a fake
one they don't eat it no it's real oh
what but you don't believe it he don't
no I hate seeing like cuz like smack
knows like she she always Point him out
cuz she's like oh you hate that huh
because I I'm like why are you out why
are you walking there so if you guys
really pay attention there's so many out
there and I asked smack I'm like is this
a girl thing and and then she's like
yeah I think I think a lot like maybe
they twist her ankle on a heel weak ass
legs heels but then they have to wear
that boot you know when you break your
foot you got to wear that boot now that
I've said it it's going to activate it
in your life what pisses you off that
they're still walking cuz their steps
are uneven I'm like [__] stay home oh
yeah or they'll go to like things that
require so much walking they'll go to
the [__] Vintage Market or the
festival and they're just like they're
walking hella and I'm like dude take a
break it's that a flea Mar you know what
they need is that little bicycle that
you put your knee on and you can but
you'll never see one on those you'll see
guys on that you won't see no l imagine
these chicks like they just got out of
rehab and they've been working on this
leg for a long time and they're like
okay I feel like I can find finally go
out and just go to the market again feel
like a normal person and then they go
there and Ryan's over there in the
corner like are you [__] dumb go home
and rest so you don't you don't like
fakers that's why I think it's
irrational cuz I know I'm not supposed
to be affected by that but I see it so
often that like it can't be a
coincidence anymore I'm like why is
every girl busting her ankle getting a
brace and then still going out very
common injury these ladies now now that
I've said it you're going to see it now
you just got to test them you got to
accidentally bump him and step on their
holy [__] you are
Vietnamese and then they're like oh
sorry sorry and then it's like see it's
not broken it's
like dude test them dude in my community
right there there's like people who
drive in the middle of the [__] road
and they clearly don't know where they
are what house they're going to so
they're going like not even 1 mile an
hour oh yeah and if I could press a
button and just have a space laser
destroy the vehicle and kill them inside
I would press it every time and I'd spam
it to that's that's California Behavior
year though it is dude Vegas drivers are
worse I'm sorry I love Vegas I'll know
but they drive slow they drive slow in
Vegas dude everyone yeah going from
California to Vegas like driving wise
must be tough it's tough there's a lot
of slow but there's also a lot of drunk
I realized a lot of drunk so it's it's
at least in California you have like
drunk good drivers cuz they're used to
doing it but Vegas like I've almost got
[__] sideswipe hella times cuz
they'll run Reds or they'll just like
not even look when they
uh change change lanes the only Bill
that went up for me when I moved to to
Vegas from California was car
insurance lot of accidents more likely
to be accidents and all that kind of
[__] oh you know what I [__] hate
sorry I [__] hate when I can't text
and
drive problem does your does your body
like anticipate what's going to happen
so for example I'm driving right and I'm
like I see the red light so my hand
already goes to the phone I go like this
and I hate when I get to the phone it's
green I'm like then why were you just
green the whole time then might as well
make this a freeway a very unique gripe
dude this a
freeway I'm like what's the point of
stopping and going if we're just going
to go oh I got one I got one when you go
to the self checkout line and the person
that is ahead of you one you I almost
always get cut as I'm going to the
self you would you would though cuz it's
like open right yeah cuz like the line
is like there's a little [__] thing
that says like oh line starts here so I
line up like a [__] [__] and then
the person just goes oh they just go
straight to the [__] thing and I'm
like okay that's one and then and then
when there's a line the people it's like
five out of six self checkouts five of
those people have never done self
checkout before why yeah why they doing
it for the first time why you doing it
for the first time a billion times
that's a good one go to the and then
they're like I got I have broccoli I
have to what's the skew number got your
all Thanksgiving dinner in your car too
for self checkout dude come it's 15
items re less dude or or it's just like
there's no sense of urgency you know
what I mean they're taking their time
and then they have to be like oh excuse
me excuse me cuz the light goes off they
[__] SC they try to buy alcohol on it
and I'm like are you [__] are they
dude you know you can't you can't buy
alcohol in a self checkout line you know
it says that are you 21 in all BR yeah
and then yeah dude it's a whole [__] oh
can I buy a gift card it's like no you
can't buy a gift C here you got to go to
the lady you know what I mean it's like
it's Supermarket stuff we all go to
supermarket right yeah is that relatable
that's relatable that's the same as like
I I hate when people are when you're in
line at like in andout or raising canes
and someone is taking a long time to
decide the options are so low how would
you not know just get the the maniac
always lines man freaking people taking
their sweet ass time dude and to go line
I mean in the car line or on the human
line human line yeah because then you
can actually audibly hear them go hm do
I want cheese or no it's like yeah
that's probably the only option bro
waiting waiting to order when you're at
the lady already oh yeah oh bro decide
before you get there you have so it's
inconsiderate yeah yeah yeah and asking
50 questions while there's a line behind
you what kind of fry oil do you use it's
like [__] go cook at home dog you worry
about the fry oil go home I also listen
to a lot of like sports [__] obviously
right like different Sports Talk radio
shows and [__] and one of the things
that drives me grinds my [__] gears
is when guys are talking about
everyone's talking about how [__] the
refs right we all hate the refs the refs
suck well I heard this one guy he's like
such a little cuck he's like he's like
you know when these ref go out there
they're doing their job and like they
blow it sometimes like these these guys
blow it sometimes or girls I'm like
there's no girl refs in the in the NFL
you [__] what the [__] you what what
youus why are you saying that there's
not one be inclusive for no reason for
no reason at all and I'm not saying and
like good I [__] beat my meat to that
fact there's no female refs I'm just
like there's no female refs why are you
including them if there's none there's a
lot in
Halloween on Halloween there yeah
there's a lot of female refs on
Halloween on Halloween yeah but that's
because they're pretending oh oh dude
they wear mustaches this is another
thing I hate when going to K toown going
to Korean Barbecue on all you can eat
place and the [__] waiter avoids your
eye contact the whole night I hate
waiters out of ey they're too busy
they don't want you order more meat I
don't want to bring you any water or
anything they Dodge your eyes so I don't
want to see you that's why good customer
service at a Korean barbecue or all you
could eat spot is very important you
know absolutely cuz you need to get that
second order I know a good one in sum oh
yeah [__] your dude we had pass we had
a dude in town who he owns a cream
barbecue restaurant back in in like
Baltimore and he we were taking them out
and then the uh the the server was like
what do you want and the guy was like oh
how does it work cuz he it works
differently out there here it's like
column A B and C or whatever and then
you choose what you want from that
column so he's like um I think I'll just
have column A and the guy was like yeah
what do you want and he was like column
A I don't understand how like what do
you mean cuz you're supposed to pick
from it but he didn't know that and the
guy wasn't explaining to him and then so
he the guy was like okay and he walked
away and then my friend who owns
restaurant's like how are we supposed to
know how this works I love when people
get mad at you when you don't know the
[__] menu like that we've had waiters
mad at us cuz we wanted water can I get
some
water yeah it's like that was my first
question I wasn't even asking you
anything yeah I was at a taco truck here
like two months ago when we were last
year for the last block and uh I go up
to the to the guy to to pay and it says
you can pay with a card and I'm like
great and as soon as I do that he's
like as if you're splitting the bill
eight ways I'm a scumbag dude cuzz he
has the option what do you have the
option for if I'm the biggest scumbag
yeah just say cash only right yeah
that's so funny that's how it used to be
when you used to take taxis back in the
day remember that yeah when you would
take a taxi and you paid with card they
hated they would s for the whole ride
yeah well I think everyone can agree the
robots with customer service when you
call in for the banks or anything the
customer service robots oh I just give
me a [__] human you know what the
hack is represent
00000000000000 and then it calls really
stop [__] with the phone how many
zeros is it or you just keep doing it
until they they they transfer you well I
don't know like please press One ESP
sometimes that works too sometimes I
press two because like if you press one
it might go to overseas like some you
know call center or whatever right but
if you press two usually it's Mexican
Americans oh that's so then you you I I
don't know I accidentally pressed two
one time it was Spanish and I was like
oh sorry I I uh hit the wrong number and
then they spoke English and I was like
oh what a good hack
wow hit that number and then 00000000
until someone comes up you can hear the
anger in your zeros too I love itess the
[__] out your I think customer service
will always be like it's either the best
or the worst like but most of the time
it's like it makes me the angriest
customers are also the worst too yeah
yeah yeah and they're going off of their
experiences too the workers I really
there's there's another really specific
thing but like when you're in like
Universal Studios or Disneyland or
something a theme park and then there's
like a um let's say you're in the
elevator that goes to the right and it's
themed and then you have the worker in
the elevator who's playing a role and
he's like welcome to the dungeon right
and he's doing his best and he's like
really into it and then you have a
[__] teenager that's [__] around
with him bro I want to [__] those guys
up I hate those kids I want I want them
to be gone you think you're so [__]
funny dude like this guy's got passion
in his work and that's going to kill it
like doing his job and then they're
they're crushing it for the kids that
are there exactly and I really just want
to [__] you [__] [__] di I
hate that when when you have somebody or
an adult an adult even like when they're
just like demystifying that guy's
effort the only time that it's is chill
for me is during the Harry Potter Juan
chooses you ceremony what happens there
I those guys are like [__] going for
it dude like it's like and by the way if
you're it's like they're all theater
actors but like we're really closed
confined space so they're just yelling
at you they're throwing the they're
throwing their voice to the back of the
room and it's like you don't have to do
this performing to the back of theater
and they're like they're like good good
evening like oh my God soon as like soon
as that started cuz I I went to you
wanted to [__] up Dumbledore huh oh bro
as soon as that [__] started he's like
good evening everyone and and and I was
just immediately like okay holy [__]
we're in for it now good evening you
have to go through it to get your wand
well I didn't want the wand I was there
to watch and silently judge and then
[__] on it later oh I appreciate workers
like that putting character even the
ones that don't have to like they're
just the guys at the line welcome to the
Tower of teror yeah yeah that's fun it's
like you're not supposed to say that but
thanks I love that stuff man I feel like
can doesn't get angry at much stuff I
actually don't but when I do it's
usually road rage stuff where people are
driving stupid or whatever like the
typical stuff that you get mad at can't
even imagine well his mad is probably
like no it's
not no no okay so I I say I got to park
my car I'm so
angry no I saved my anger for like the
really important stuff you save it don't
save it when people are like screwing
you over or like Rel ship like really
like stuff that that means stuff to me
that's when I really get upset like when
I get disappointed at people or whatever
it's always like something where it's
like oh you should know better you know
and that's what you're really
like yeah I'm like come on man I'm still
Smiley I'm like hey come on man do
better when it's time to fight dude I'm
going to let him have it K just lets his
hair down he goes takes the ponytail
right down all right I'm let all right
I'm angry now dude such a nice guy dude
yeah yep for real you're good you're
you're a good dude man no you're a good
dude dude don't make me angry you're a
good dude you're a good
dude